[Musique]
notre pays est un grand pays agricole
nous pouvons et nous devons le rester à
la condition que les agriculteurs qui
sont parfois les premières victimes des
politiques qui ont été menées
comprennent que l'environnement et la
chance de l'agriculture de demain
nous ne connaissons rien d effet sur le
moyen et le long terme des organismes
génétiquement modifiés depuis 1996 je
demande un moratoire sur la mise en
culture des ogm
je l'avais fait en tant que ministre
j'ai continué en tant que citoyen
[Musique]
il ne s'agit évidemment pas d'être
contre le progrès mais il s'agit d'être
pour un progrès maîtriser celui qui ne
serait pas de la version lite et corinne
lepage dans notre pays chacun est
préoccupé par la qualité de son
alimentation elle justifiée bien sûr la
sécurité alimentaire et est une grande
préoccupation
on aurait pu éviter la maladie de
creutzfeldt jacob en appliquant le
principe de précaution la sécurité
alimentaire c'est sous tendu aussi par
notre population d'agriculteurs et
l'agriculture dans cet ensemble
certainement une agriculture moins
chimique qu utilisent moins de
pesticides moins d'engrais - nitrates
une agriculture qui favorise le label
les produits terroir l'agriculture
biologique une agriculture qui
permettent aux agriculteurs et je pense
notamment aux petites et moyennes
exploitations agricoles de vivre
décemment
nous avons besoin de garder un vrai
monde rural nous avons besoin d'un autre
équilibre entre les villes et les
campagnes
les citadins aux besoins du monde rural
et l'oublient trop souvent je suis donc
favorable à une nouvelle ruralité à une
renaissance rural
[Musique]